How can an influential
and exclusive business
become more inclusive?
Educator and disability
advocate Sinéad Burke
is on a mission to change the way
fashion is represented in our world.
When this process first began,
which was almost two years ago,
it was for a need and an urgency for
the National Museums of Scotland
because they were doing this exhibition
on the diversity of fashion.
Sinéad has achondroplasia,
a form of dwarfism,
and identifies as a little person.
I asked how they were going
to exhibit my clothes.
They said that they were gonna
hang them from the ceiling.
I asked how everything else
was going to be displayed
and they said, well, mannequins.
So really, almost flippantly, I said,
"Okay, well how do we
get a mannequin made?"
How cool is that?
It's amazing.
I met with experts,
executives, and advocates
in London and Paris who want to see
the gilded doors of the
fashion business thrown open.
I certainly experienced tremendous racism.
I didn't fit the very narrow profile
of what was acceptable.
Together, we're going to explore not just
the moral argument, but the business case
for letting everyone in.
What we wear says a lot about who we are,
yet fashion is also a $2.5
trillion global industry
that touches everyone on Earth.
I'm Imran Amed.
I first started trying to make sense
of the fashion business 15 years ago
as it was being transformed by technology,
globalization, and
shifting consumer values.
Now I'm on a journey to see how fashion
is recalibrating amid the pandemic
to balance profit with purpose.
This is "The Business of Fashion" show.
Join me to discover how
fashion shapes business,
culture, and identity,
and to meet the people
forging fashion's future.
The luxury business is
built on exclusivity.
Fashion can appear inclusive
in terms of ethnicity,
body shape, and age.
And designers may have shone
a broader light on beauty,
but a caution about always
taking fashion at face value.
Analysis of thousands of images posted by
leading luxury brands on Instagram
revealed that light skinned models
continue to dominate fashion imagery.
And when it comes to
decision makers at the top,
in the design studio or the boardroom,
the seats of power
remain largely unchanged.
It's good to witness
visible and vocal advocates,
from trans icons to gender
nonconforming people.
Fashion is doing more
to count everyone in,
yet the business case for creating
more diversity inside fashion companies
is even more powerful,
leading to higher levels of profitability.
Businesses with the most ethnic
and gender diversity
outperform the least diverse
by as much as 36%
and they are much more
likely to tilt the lens
to spot new business opportunities
such as a largely untapped
15% of the world's
population who have disabilities
and a spending power
topping $1.2 trillion.
No wonder fashion is paying attention.
The wider positive trend,
boardroom diversity widens
the perspective at the top.
Entry-level pathways are no longer
reserved only for those
who can afford to take them
because the bottom line,
to the benefit of shareholders
in society at large
is that belonging is good business.
Since this is an episode about belonging,
it's important to say a few things
about my own identity upfront.
I am am Ismaili-Muslim
man of Indian origin,
born in Canada to
immigrants from East Africa.
I was an outsider when I started
sneaking into fashion shows in 2005.
Back then, the front rows were a uniform,
narrow representation of the world.
Now, I am invited into
elite fashion spaces
where the front rows are changing.
One stalwart is Edward Enninful,
the first Black man to be appointed as
the Editor in Chief of
Conde Nast British Vogue.
At the Paris couture shows,
I was also reunited with Samira Nasr
who became Editor in
Chief of Harper's Bazaar,
owned by fashion's other
media giant, Hearst.
After a long day of shows,
we met to talk about everything that has
happened since the
beginning of the pandemic,
including her rise to the
very top of fashion media.
Her premiere issue was poignant,
examining the paradox of being first.
Your appointment in this role was
not just a big change for you,
it represented pretty significant shift
for Harper's Bazaar, for fashion media,
the first woman of color ever in the
history of Harper's Bazaar at the helm.
What did it mean to you personally,
but what do you think it also signified
for all those young women from
different backgrounds who never saw
someone like you in a role like this?
I think that in that
moment, everyone felt seen.
I think it was so much about me and
people rooting for me,
but I think ultimately,
people were also rooting
for their likeness.
It's an acknowledgement of all people
who have felt not seen and it just means
that more people can dream and aspire
to something that they
never thought they could,
and that's a beautiful thing.
What does real inclusion
look like in fashion?
Walk down the street.
To me, that's exactly what it should mean.
You shouldn't be excluded because
where you come from,
or what you look like,
or your sexual orientation,
or how you identify yourself,
it should just be are you
willing to do the work
and do you have the passion to try.
That's what every
industry should look like.
Back in the days when you first
started, what was it like?
It was hard and I certainly experienced
tremendous racism.
Within the industry?
Oh my gosh, yeah.
I've had some horrible things said to me.
Having to go meet an editor,
a big, powerful editor
and everyone's like okay,
you have to go meet this editor and
let's make sure you look okay and then
someone says, so and so
editor doesn't like messy hair
and so all the people who are around me
who are trying to help me get
ready are like, oh my God.
And I'm looking.
Who has messy hair?
And I realize 'cause my hair,
when it's out, it's very big,
and I realized they're talking about me
and that's just one example of
my natural texture hair was messy.
I didn't fit the very narrow
profile of what was acceptable.
So now that you're in
the role that you're in,
you must feel a great
sense of responsibility.
This role isn't about me, it's about we.
It's about the community
that I can bring together
and share these platforms
and elevate these voices
and bring them along with
me, so it's about the we.
But I believe we all
have a responsibility.
It's like you get through the door
and every one of us
has a responsibility to
look back from where you came and
extend your hand and
pull someone in with you,
but this industry isn't
entirely filled with
horrible people.
I feel like we have to
change that narrative also
'cause I love this industry.
Why do you love this industry?
It's everything.
It reflects our times, it is
a community, it's creative,
it is a social commentary,
it's kind of a social experiment, really.
So many misfits who find their way in
and find their voice and their place
and we get to dream, you know?
We saw two incredible shows today and
those people are part of my community.
And we get to do that.
Cheers.
We'll always have couture.
We will.
Samira's idea of using her influence
to open doors for others sticks with me
as I head back to London.
Every year, "The Business of
Fashion" hosts a live event
called "Voices", our annual
gathering for big thinkers.
In 2017, disability advocate Sinead Burke
addressed an audience of fashion leaders
and explained how the
industry systematically
excludes disabled people.
I have had an insatiable interest
in the fashion industry for
as long as I can remember
despite having such limited access to it.
As founder as CEO of "Tilting the Lens",
a consultancy that brings
visibility to inaccessibility,
Sinéad advises companies like Gucci
and Ralph Lauren on moving
from awareness to action.
When I meet with Sinéad in London,
we start by reflecting on
her journey from "Voices"
and how her goals have
changed along the way.
When you meet someone now,
how do you describe who
you are and what you do?
It's funny.
I think if we were having this
conversation five years ago,
I probably would've
described myself, first,
because of my visual identity in the
sense that I have dwarfism,
that I'm a little person,
I'm a disabled woman.
Whilst I still use that language,
I'd probably talk about my
interests and my work more now,
not because those aren't
defined by my disability,
because they are.
I understood that when
people looked at me,
they had assumptions over
what I could and couldn't do
based on my aesthetic.
And I knew within my own instincts that
fashion had this power
to tell a new story,
one that I had agency over,
because I'm giving you permission
to enter into my world, to learn who I am,
and yet despite knowing the
power of fashion to do that,
I never felt represented or seen
or able to buy the clothes
that I felt comfortable in.
The vulnerability that we've shared
with each other in private moments
has really emboldened me on my
own purpose in this industry.
And I was someone who kind
of put my own identity
in the background.
Some of the challenge
around visible identities
is that as much as we try to pocket them,
the world stills sees us as that.
I may not describe myself as disabled,
but the world sees me as disabled,
the fashion system sees me as disabled
and me not having pride around that
gives them permission to own whatever
narrative they think
disability exists with them.
I imagine that's the
same with being Muslim,
being gay, being an immigrant.
Tell me what happened after "Voices".
Afterwards?
I felt vulnerable because
I had exposed myself,
personally,
but also professionally.
I had just told the industry
I knew what they needed to do.
Did I?
I had no idea.
I haven't since then.
And what happened afterwards was
more and more conversations,
initially with individuals,
then with friends and companies.
It was appearing on stages
with microphone in my hand,
going to fashion shows.
It was incredible.
Five years ago, if you were
to ask me what success was,
I would've said the
availability of clothes.
My vision has widened.
I really do think the availability
of product is important
because I think it's more important
that we are hiring disabled
people within these companies.
That's what I wanna change.
Voices like Sinéad's matter,
but how do we measure progress?
One challenge is the lack of robust data.
In the key European fashion economies of
France, Italy, and Germany,
companies cannot collect
personal data on identity
due to national privacy laws.
The U.K. goes the furthest,
asking its citizens each Census to
volunteer their racial, physical,
sexual, and gender identities.
So to continue our discussion,
Sinéad and I meet with two
leaders in British fashion
to share their own experiences.
June Sarpong is a broadcaster, activist,
author, and the first
director of creative diversity
at the BBC.
Jamie Gill is CEO of luxury
fashion brand Roksanda.
Both are non-executive directors
of the British Fashion Council,
appointed in the wake of the
"Black Lives Matter" protests.
June and Jamie, I just
wanted to start very quickly
maybe with you first, June.
How do you identify and
what is your personal story?
My Britishness in a way is a sort of
the link for me to the world, you know?
It's a wonderful identity to be able
to take with you globally.
Everybody sort of
connects with Britishness.
I would say my Ghanaian in culture
for sure is my foundation.
That's my roots.
And then my race is something that I am
so immersed in and with and also
impacts my experience in so many ways.
Jamie, how 'bout you?
How do you identify?
Identify.
I would identify myself as a
British-Indian gay man, I think.
And I'd add on Londoner
I think to that as well.
Yes!
I forgot that.
That was one thing, I
was thinking about it,
I was like, yeah, we say British,
but I think there's, you
know, as we all know,
there's a culture of being from London
that I very much champion and I think
growing up my whole life and coming from
a working class background as well
and growing up in the Midlands and being
a minority on so many regards,
I saw those as just such hindrances.
Such hindrances that I carried with me,
that weighed me down, that
didn't allow me to be free.
So we're here talking about belonging
in the fashion industry and
you both, all of us, actually,
were outsiders.
Oh yeah!
All of us.
None of us came up through
a traditional path.
No.
But we've all found our way
somehow into this industry.
Some people outside might think
we don't have a diversity
problem, for that regard,
but operationally, the
people from any different
kind of background I think
is very, very minimal
and I think working in a
kind of smaller business,
but if we were to look bigger
and we would look at
listed companies out there
even within the kind of fashion space
is what acts sees sweet.
It is nonexistent.
But are we at a point now where we need
measurables, KPIs?
Like what does success look
like when it's delivered?
I don't think we have an
example of success yet,
and that's the issue.
So we're asking people
to imagine something
that perhaps in any industry, actually,
has never really existed,
at least not at scale.
The first thing to do is to connect
with the most disenfranchised group
within your organization and ask them
what their experience
is of your organization.
That's gonna tell you
everything about your culture.
Well, it raises a really
interesting question
about our industry as a whole, though,
is like this industry was
designed around exclusivity.
It is.
So is there a way of reconciling that
exclusivity in terms
of prize, or scarcity,
or access, or being in the room with
inclusion and belonging and equity?
Yes!
And that what it should've been
designed around is aspiration,
in that it's about all of us wanting
to be the best version of ourselves.
If you look at accessories,
accessories are about aspiration,
accessories are the entry point for
people who can't afford the actual clothes
et cetera, et cetera.
They knew they had to do that because
of the financial benefits.
Why can't we apply that same thinking
for everything that
we're talking about here?
Amongst this monoculture
that fashion still is,
especially on the business side,
how do we also do it in a way
that people aren't so scared?
When we talk about the
changes that are needed,
we need to be really frank that
for those who have been used to privilege,
equity feels like oppression.
Like oppression, yes.
Cindy Gallop.
She's right!
Because in order for
others to take up space,
some have to retract.
So that pattern of behavior that they've
been practicing in terms
of what leadership is...
Won't work anymore.
No longer exists.
So it's not that we need to replace
every CEO with somebody
who looks different.
It's not functional, nor it is practical,
nor is it the way we need to move forward.
We've got to do something visually,
very externally projecting
that we are welcoming
and there are roles available,
at least from the operational side,
like what is it like to
be an operations director
of a fashion business and why does that
skillset actually maybe lean in to
what you think you want to be doing?
So I think we do need to be
working on that as a collective.
If we go back to the ways in which
we have always done
things, what does it take?
People to die?
If we look at George Floyd,
if we look at the pandemic,
it requires us to lose
people in order to change.
The great thing is is that
between the four of us,
we can probably change a
sizable portion of the world.
With that on our minds,
Sinéad and I head over
to Proportion London,
one of the UK's largest manufacturers
of mannequins for the retail industry.
Today, Sinéad is having the final casting
to complete a mannequin of her body,
which can be used as a model for other
little people to be better
represented in fashion.
Hello!
Gaetano, this is Imran.
Imran, this is Gaetano.
Hi.
Nice to meet you.
How are you?
I am all right.
Thank you for having us.
It's such a treat.
You wanna put this one on.
This is gonna be the most glamorous fit
of the entire fashion show.
Like couture has nothing on us, Gaetano.
Sinéad, this is the second
time you're doing this, right?
Yeah.
So do you wanna tell us a little bit
about how this mannequin
situation happened?
So the National Museums of Scotland
were putting together this exhibition
called "Body Beautiful".
They were the first ever
cultural institution
to do an exhibition with
diversity in fashion
and when it came to disability,
they asked if they could
borrow some of my clothes.
And one of those items
was the trench coat,
which I had actually saved from the
"Voices of Fashion" shoot and I said,
how are you gonna display my clothes?
And the initial suggestion was that
they would hang them from the ceiling.
A lovely idea, but I asked
how was everything else
being displayed?
And they just said mannequins.
I said, okay, great.
How do we get a mannequin
made for my clothes?
I can't tickle her right now, right?
No.
So after this mannequin is
done, what's gonna happen?
My hope is that first,
we kind of tackle the education system
and that we're able to collaborate with
Central Saint Martins, Parsons, FIT,
the National College of
Art and Design in Ireland,
to make these available for students
because if we have
mannequins, all of a sudden,
fit becomes a different
conversation, and from then,
it would be great to see this mannequin
in retail spaces visually,
but we need product first.
And you don't have anything to
put on the mannequin yet.
No.
So putting clothes that
may fit is one thing,
but it needs to be in the tailors,
it needs to be in design studios,
and we need to be looking at this
as a way in which to get it into CAD also
and thinking about the measurements.
Amazing.
You see that and went mhm.
Yeah.
Just a little bit longer than this.
My mannequin is a composite of me.
My lumps, my bumps, my curves, me.
And when I first saw
the mannequin in person,
I was really insecure about it because
it didn't look like any of
the mannequins that I had seen
and I was almost joking about
the size and the measurements
and I was uncomfortable with it,
but I'm not uncomfortable with me.
It's the world making me feel like I don't
conform to everything else, and actually,
it's that discomfort that
proves the importance of this.
As soon as you told me
that this was happening,
I wanted to be apart of
it and just witness it
because it felt pretty monumental.
It wasn't until I saw all of
these mannequins around me
that I realized that in a place like this
where these body shapes
and these body types
are then replicated over,
and over, and over again
and show up in retail
stores and in design studios
and in schools that that's why we
all develop these ideas of
what body shape should be.
And it wasn't until seeing you
in this space that that
was reinforced for me.
Marginalized communities are not
looking for special
treatment from fashion,
they're looking for equal treatment.
There are certainly powerful, moral,
and business arguments for doing so,
but the question remains,
how prepared is the fashion
industry to take real action?